ちー様ことでくよくよしていてもしょうがないな
星あ宇宙に接すると不思議なぐらーにそう感じる方が多いようです
皆さんはいかがですか
私は
ここを長野県
北安曇郡八坂村で生まれ育ちました
こんな場所です
八坂は今では町村合併で大町市に併合されてしまいましたけれども
このようにスターアルプスに近い自然豊かな
村です
子供の頃から私はなぜか星や宇宙にとりつかれてしまい大好きになってしまいました
この家から見える
2アルプスの山並みをみては
あの山の向こうには一体
何があるのか誰が住んでいるのか
そして夜になるとこの山の上に満天の星空が広がるのですが
この広大な宇宙はいったいどこまで広がっているのか
宇宙には我々以外にも生き物がいるのかどうか
そんなことをいつも気になって気になってしょうがなかったんです
そこで
私は天文学を学びたいと
最初は木本ここ信州大学にもう
喜びサインで入学したんです
ところがですね
この
宇宙研
信州長野県ですね当時1人も支持大学天文学者がいなかったんですねびっくりしました
私はしかし宇宙を研究する有名がどうしてもどうしても諦めきれなくて
せっかく入った信州大学松本の下宿をですねたった数が2ヶ月で引き払って
否か八坂に帰ってしまったんです
当時
親にも迷惑を掛けましたし
絶望のどん底にいた私は
知らないうちに深夜
村のはずれにある崖の上に立っていました
身を投げようと崖のふち技ですね
近づいてってそっと空を見上げたらそこにはですね
東の空から
大きな獣がライオンがですね勢いよく
空に駆け上がってきてたのです
そう獅子座ですね
この雄大な
獅子座を見て
私は思いましたや今はこんなちっぽけなことで人生9よくを引いてもしょうがないん
じゃないかなって
そのとき思ったんです
でそのことがですね私を再度自分の夢に向かって挑戦する
力をパワーを与えてくれました
そして現在の私が今ここにいます
とはいってもですね私が自分の夢が叶って天文学の研究をするために
国立天文台に入ったのは38際の時でした大学を卒業して14年間は東京都内の学校で
中学校や高校で理科の教師を
きていました
14年間の森いろいろありますけども特に定時制高校
4年間
教えたことをそれがを振り返ってみるとですね私の人生の中において
最大の自分の人生を決めていくサイダーの出来事だったような気がしてなりません
で自制というと皆さんはどんなイメージを持ちですか
手子生の出身の方っていらっしゃるんでしょうかこの中にはあのマーク学生
苦労してあの学校に通う
というイメージだと思うんですけど私が教鞭をとっていた
1980年代の都内の定時制高校はそういう様子ではなくて3分の1はですね
まあ低学力でまぁ受験でその他の昼間の学校に入れなかった子どもたち
3分の1がですねいわゆるヤンキーな子達ですね
暴力を振るったとか暴走族で活躍しているとかそういう学校
なじまない退学になってしまった形
そして残りの3分の1が当時はまだそういう言葉がありませんでしたが今でいう不登校
の子どもたちでした
ですからめちゃくちゃ有名な皆さんも聞いたことがあるような
中学校や高校の出身でそこに通えなくなって私が勤めてるっていい成功夜間の学校に
通っている子供もいましたし
一方ですねー
自分でまあなんとか学校に通うとかトイレにはいけるんですけども耳も十分にかけない
ような
お子さん達もいました
中にはですね教室でこうやって目と目が合った途端ですね僕に飛びかかってくる
先行俺にガンつけやがってっていうそういうあの本当にヤンキーというか暴走族のあん
ちゃんもいたんですね
そんなクラスそんな子たちが40人50人いるクラス授業なんか成立するはずがない
だろうって皆さん
思われることでしょう
しかしまぁだいたいそうな授業なかなか成立の代だったんですけれども
彼らはとても優しいすぎる優しすぎるというか正直すぎるためにですね
社会から聞いてあげられてきた子たちが多かったんですね
とてもとても愛情に飢えていました
ですから
休み時間になると職員室の前には行列ができていてとにかく
話を聞いて欲しい話をしたいそういう愛情に飢えた子供たちだったんです
ですから授業でも受験勉強とか全然関心ないんですが本質的な内容
とても大事なことに関してはとっても食いつきの良いところがありました
例えばですね
当時は日本では a is
という病気がとても社会問題になっていましたがそういったことについては真剣に愛情
とかセックスとかそういうことに対して非常に真剣にあの向かい合ってくれましたし
そんな子たちがですね不思議なことにかなりの割合で星や宇宙に興味を持ってくれたん
です
私のすべては学校の屋上には thom があり
天体望遠鏡がありました理科の授業
そこに停車の子供たちを連れて行って例えば
月を見たり女性を見たいそんな授業をしているとですね
普段はまったく興味を示さない子供たち生徒たちが
先生を励行もんだけどて私に議論を吹っかけてくるんです
宇宙人はいるかいないかというので
生徒たちと田井議論をしたことがありました
まあそのような議論の後生徒の中月
何かつぶやいたのはまあ宇宙ってとこは宇宙だけは平等な社会なんだな
世界なんだなーとかこれから少し上を向いて歩こうかな
上を見上げてみようかなそんなことを言ってくれる生徒もいました
今日時代はですね本当にとても楽しくてやりがいのある日々でした
でもあるとき気がついてしまったのですが
私たちが教師となって一生を働いた場合ですね何人くらいのせいとうさんとこう
付き合えるか
対応できると思います計算してみるとですね
わずか6000人から8000人くらいの人なんです
で私は自分が好きな線があるんだと思うんですけど私がこう熱く語る
星や宇宙について多くの子たちが慣習を持ってくれたのでもっともっと多くの若者たち
に宇宙のことを伝えたいと思いました
特に下を向いて生きている人たち
友達ができない未来に夢を描けない
うまく回りとやっていけない
ネガティブになってしまっていると
新がない
そういう人たちにこそ宇宙のことを知ってもらいたいなって思ったんです
まあ宇宙のことを知ったからといってですね目の前の事が解決するわけでありません
から
ポン人たちにとって本質的な解決は何もないかもしれませんけれども
私の経験やそれまでの
まあここさと付き合いの中で
感じたことはその人によってはまたはそのタイミングによってはですね
タイミングによっては何かを変えられる
少し振動道筋を変えることができるかもしれないと思ったんです
私がそうだったようにまた私やであった
何かの生徒たちがそうだったように
こんなことでくよくよしてもしょうがない乗り越えていこうってそう思えるかもしれな
いって思ったんです
ところで皆さんは何かそれぞれ心のよりどころとか自分の人生をかけようっていう夢を
持ちですか
いたがでしょう
自分の存在理由や立ち位置がわからないことほど
大人になると不安なことはありません
逆に言うなら自分の存在理由を siri
自分が生きる目的を知ることができれば人々の生き方は大きく変わっ大きく変わる可能
性があるのです
宇宙のことを知る
宇宙のことを知ると自分の存在理由や立ち位置について
それが垣間見える瞬間に遭遇することが
ありますこれは宇宙を探求している
研究者の特権では決してありません
誰でもが気づくチャンスがあります
そして変わるのは一人一人
個人だけではありません
星や宇宙を身近に感じる
天文文化が
発展途上国でも住んでいます
その最も顕著な例は南米のコロンビアです
メディ銀という街ご存知の方いらっしゃいますか
私たち日本人にとっては全く馴染みのないこの女ディンという器用ですね
2013年
ウォールとストリートジャーナル費が最も革新的な町
第1位に選んでるんです入浴とか東京
10日を
超えてですよ第一です
そのまちづくりの中心が
美術
音楽
スポーツと並んで科学であり宇宙なんです
つまり
美術館や
スタジアムや
音が凍ると並んで科学館やプラネタリウムを街の人たちがとてもとても誇りに思い
大事にしていることを私は昨年元気に
方も現地を訪問して知ることになりました
ご存知常にコロンビアは
治安の悪い国でした
ここ数年大きな改革が行われました
それまでの治安の悪さや
国内のいろんな対立を乗り越えようとしてきました
2012年
このようにこの日アレジンに
近代的なプランタリウム館が完成し
そこの館長のカルロスさんが私に大変興味深いエピソード
話してくれました
このプラネタリウムに
15歳ぐらいのギャング団の若者たちが
集まって集団で行ってきました
そしてこのプランタリウムの番組を観終わって出てきたとき
ギャング団の
リーダーの子がこういったそうです
武器をせよ
俺たちはいつも狭いってりとりあら採用はこの街の中で繰り返してきたけれども
間違ってた
地球全体が折れた木の体とリーダー
なんかもう武器を捨て様ってですね
これは実話ですそれから構想が収まり
若者たちは学校に履い通い始めたそうです
そもそもですねこれらの問題多くの場合は貧しいことが全ての元凶にあります
科学技術が豊かさをもたらしてくれると発展途上効果にも多くの国の人々が信じてい
ます
しかし科学技術が発達するのみで得られる物質的な豊かさや経済的な豊かさのみならず
星や宇宙
ま
心の豊かさをも私たちにもたらせてくれるという一つの例ではないかと思うのです
つまり地球にすぐ713億人もの
我々人類そのものの存在理由や
これからのミッション未来をですね考えるその上で
沢山のことがもちろん私たちは考えなきゃいけませんけどそのなかの1つとして私たち
は
点からの文を読み解き
宇宙を理解するということが必要ではないかと思うのです
では短い時間になりますがここでその番組の内容をですね
同じように私がここで再現してみたいと思います
黒点もだで私が所属している方 d 2 u というプロジェクトことが開発した
いたかというソフトを持っていますけどこれ今北の空です
で
北の空を上がっていきますが
プランタイムの番組ではメディの街がまず映し出されます
そして日からどんどんフレームアウトしていきます
地球のその
コロンビアが見えてきて南米大陸が見えてきてそして地球全体の姿が大きく大きな画面
で目の前に浮かび上がるわけですそうです
地球の姿です
今はここ新種7から飛び上がりましたけど
このようなまあるい地球な目の前で
ぐるぐると自転している様子24時間で1周している様子を彼らは見たわけです
そしてその地球は
月を連れて
太陽系の中に位置しています太陽系の第三惑星です
太陽中心に水星金星地球火星
たくさんの小惑星巨大の木星や土星天王星海王星の外側にも
ちっちゃな今の10代たちがたくさんいます太陽系は太陽気球間の距離の約1万倍もの
広がりがありますこれが
彗星の素ですそしてみてください
沢山の星々というのは星座をつくっている星々です獅子座やオリオン座
北杜市西
織姫彦星もありますこのような星々の中でいま
目では見えないけれども
沢山の剥製たちが確認されつつあります
太陽系のまにま黄色い収集をした星々の周りには
太陽系と同じように惑星が存在しているのでそこには
生命が住む星がある可能性があります
とても高い可能性です
でそのような星を進んだ銀河というものによって宇宙全体が構成されてそれが138億
光年の広がりを持っているというのがその
彼らが見た番組と同じ
イメージです
切り替えましょう
大げさかもしれませんでも私は
宇宙を見る視点をすべての人がこのように見ることにこのように保つことによってそれ
は世界平和につの枚つながるのではないかと思っているんです
世界平和はこの瞬間の夜中のことだけ見ても全く解決しません
過去に学ぶことも大事ですでも
それだけでは不十分未来を見据えるということが大事です
宇宙は4次元です時間と空間です
宇宙を研究することによって実は私たちは一体どこから生まれどこに行こうとしている
かと言う
未来も見えてくるんです
私たちが大事にしている原理は宇宙原理と言います
宇宙原理というのは宇宙の中で私たちのこの
身近で成り立っている法則は遠く離れたはるか彼方の宇宙でも同じような物理法則や
同じような化学物質でそして同じように1ものがどこかにいるかもしれないと
いう考え方です
宇宙原理
つまり宇宙の中でのこの適用されるルールというのを私たちは人類
そのものの基本原理として考える必要がある時期を迎えています
私たちは宇宙を学ぶことによって
に人類にとって私たち人間にとっての宇宙原理普遍性というものを見つける必要がある
と思います
もちろん今皆さんが隣の人と見比べ打ってみたら違うことだけでしょう
宇宙の中でも地球と火星では
特徴が違うありますけど違いますしかし大きな宇宙全体天の川銀河とかそういう
スケールでものを見てみるとですね
火星と地球の違いというのはわずかです石でできていてそこには生き物がいるかもしれ
ないということです
そしてそのような生き物がいるかもしれない星がもう我々の太陽系の外側
3600個見つかっています
近い将来知的生命体と更新をするような事態がもう目の前にやってきているのです
私たちはあ
今
こういう子奪回を迎え自分たちにとっての宇宙原理を見つけ
人と人とのいざ会や国と苦味とノイ境を解決していく
ローカルな視野にとらわれることなく私たちにとっての普遍的なるーるー
お互いの共通性を見出し争いを解決していく必要があるのではないでしょうか
そうすればわたしたちは戦うべき敵ではなくお互いが仲間だと感じられるはずです
宇宙をもっと多くの人に知ってほしい
宇宙そのことによって
人類にとっての宇宙原理を知ることができればそれが今の私のミッションです
皆さんとともに歩んでいければと思います静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]